it's friday and that means it's time for
friday follies and for that we turn to
fox news contributor raymond arroyo
raymond the bidens uh did a big
big vax push this week with uh
well they their shots didn't all hit
did they well like the vaccine in some
cases
look the president explained the vaccine
reluctance of african americans
and hispanics this way laura
there's a reason why it's been harder to
get african-americans
initially to get vaccinated because
they're used to being experimented on
the tuskegee airmen and others it's
awful hard
as well to get latinx
vaccinated as well why they're worried
that they'll be vaccinated and deported
laura there's so much wrong with those
quotes i don't know where to begin
first of all victims of the tuskegee
syphilis experiments
and the tuskegee airmen are two entirely
different group of people
that shared a town okay it's like saying
we owe a lot to those native american
chiefs
like those kansas city chiefs no one or
a group of tribal leaders the other is a
football team
and as for the latinx or as you say
latinx this this
is even more concerning first off i
don't know any hispanics in my
family or anywhere else that use latinx
they just don't a pew survey showed
only three percent of mostly young
people even entertained that term
i personally don't think it's that high
and then the idea
that hispanics or that biden thinks
hispanics
aren't getting vaccinated because they
fear deportation
i know a lot of hispanics right here in
new orleans i'd like to introduce them
to
none of them fear deportation by the way
first of all who
who in the country right now would ever
fear
deportation including convicted
murderers
okay i don't see that anyone is getting
deported
any time soon so we can just allay the
concerns of
anyone who's worried okay they're
they're i mean biden just wants you to
stay forever and vote democrat and so
does harris we'll get to that
and laura president biden he needed a
lot of help this week
his handlers had their hands full trying
to
keep him on schedule and kamala harris
played the role of prompter to remind
him of that surfside building collapse
watch
will you travel to florida can we ask
you about florida what you've learned
yes i apologize yes thank you my
uh i've spoken with coincidentally the
mayor
of miami are you mr president have you
called governor desantis
july celebrations have you called
governor desantis mr president
mr president come on this way joe this
way
come home there was a hand pushing him
off stage or off
yeah well sometimes you need a little
more help laura i mean
harrison ford who's a year older than
joe biden just injured himself on the
set of that new indiana jones movie in
london
maybe if he had had some handlers
indiana jones and the fractured shoulder
blade
might still be shooting but you know you
need help from your friends
laura sometimes to save you from
yourself and that's what i think we saw
this week i'm very confused i thought
indiana jones
was already canceled because he was too
what manly
or too chivalrous or kissed the wrong
person or i thought that was all
kiss the young girl kiss the young girl
no he's in the process of being canceled
not just yet
now laura joe biden jill biden rather
hit
the south this week to push vaccines in
tennessee mississippi and florida
this is part of her we can do this tour
only 41 of tennesseans have been
vaccinated
so jill biden tried to woo them with an
insult
this state still has a little bit of way
to go
only three in ten tennesseans are
vaccinated
and well you're booing yourselves
[Laughter]
exactly ten people showed up at dr
biden's nashville
pop-up vacs clinic laura and that was
with a free beer
and a brad paisley concert they got to
do better than this
i'm surprised with the doctor title
which is so endearing
that they wouldn't say oh doctor could
you just right here please with
i'm on my second shot now like no no no
a different type of doctor does that
mean i'm a jurist
say i got a jd am i can i be dr laura
juris doctor
yes we'll start calling you dr laura why
not everybody's a dog if you don't have
a stethoscope hanging around your neck
okay i'm just it's just i'm all
old-school that way i don't know it just
doesn't well to me
i don't know it's definitely they may
have to rename this tour
we can't do this okay the first lady's
comments in mississippi
may explain why there's so much vaccine
hesitancy listen closely to this
scientists have been studying similar
viruses
and working on this type of vaccine for
decades so when this pandemic started
they already had a pandemic
ready to go they got that pandemic ready
to go dr laura
so one in the wings you know
jill biden will be driving the pace car
at nascar next to try to get people
vaccinated i don't know where this tour
ends but let's hope it ends
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else